good afternoon everybody thank you very
very much for being here it's wonderful
to see so many of you in such a horrible
rainy day I'm sorry we couldn't provide
better weather for this very notable
event I'm Alice Prohaska I'm the Yale
University librarian and I am absolutely
delighted to welcome you to this very
special talk by Penelope lively and
David McCullough which has been
organized and sponsored by the Yale
University Library in honor of the
series that we run for our Yale library
associates we are most honored to have
these two authors of immense renown
with us today and I'm going to introduce
them in reverse order starting with mr.
McCullough and then with mrs. lively and
mrs. lively will speak first on reading
history and writing fiction
her subtitle is a life in books mr.
McCullough an admirer of Penelope
Lively's reverence for history in her
fiction will deliver a reply and this
will follow into a brief
question-and-answer period with them
both before I continue with the
introductions may I remind you all to
please turn off your cellphone's after
the talk and the question time round
about 5:45 we have a reception in
Sterling Memorial Library just along the
high street I'm sure most of you know
well how to get there and everybody will
be very welcome to join us David
McCullough has been called the master of
the art of narrative history a graduate
of Yale College in 1955 he is twice
winner of the National Book Award and
the Pulitzer Prize and he is written
about America's presidents and
revolutionary leaders Wars landmarks
bridges canals revolutionary events
knowned millions around the world
as the narrator of Ken Burns is landmark
documentary at the Civil War and of
course now for the HBO series on John
Adams in December of 2006 David
McCullough received the Presidential
Medal of Freedom the nation's highest
civilian honor his biography written in
2001 of Patriot and founding father John
Adams which is now being aired on HBO
start with Paul Giamatti as the star
recreates another link between David
McCullough and Yale since Paul Giamatti
is the son of course of former Yale
president a Bartlett Giamatti he's
currently working on a new book that and
what a wonderful topic to choose and
have very very savvy to have chosen this
topic a new book on Americans in Paris
over a hundred year period imagine how
much time the McCullough's must have to
spend in Paris from 1830 to 1930 and I'm
delighted to mention that all of us
should also watch Yale's iTunes U
website because mr. McCullough has just
recorded a guided tour of Sterling
Memorial Library with a few touches of
his own particular favorite spots it
should be available as a free
downloadable podcast within the new
fifth week next few weeks and it will be
linked from our website
Penelope lively was born in Cairo and
studied modern history at Oxford
she began her writing career as an
author of children's books which
includes the ghost of Thomas Kemp for
which she received the Carnegie Medal
and a stitch in time which won the
Whitbread award she's been nominated
three times for the Booker Prize the
annual contemporary fiction award which
is presented to writers in the British
Commonwealth and in the Republic of
Ireland and in 1987 she was awarded the
Booker Prize for her extraordinary novel
which I'm sure very many of you know
moon tiger misses
is a fellow of the Royal Society of
literature and a member of pen and a
society of authors she is an OBE which
means an Officer of the Order of the
British Empire and now a CBE commander
of the Order of the British Empire
her most recent novel consequences which
has been called flawlessly constructed
was published in June 2007 and should be
out in paperback shortly we in any day
now we trust in 2005 the Daily Telegraph
in the print published in London claimed
that it is quote the writer's job to see
patterns and turn chaos into order to
make the flow of experience and emotion
less overwhelming by a transforming
muddle and contingency into story no
writer today performs this task better
than Penelope lively well I don't think
we need expect muddle and contingency
this evening let me hand over the podium
to Penelope lively
thank you for for that Alice it's the
most tremendous pleasure and privilege
to be here today and I thank my friend
Alice Prohaska for the opportunity and
I'm greatly honored to be sharing a
platform with David McCullough I'm an
avid reader of history and as a novelist
I hugely admired David McCullough's
narrative power he tells a story many
stories reading John Adams and 1776 and
other titles I found myself in exactly
the same state of intrigue suspense as
when reading successful fiction and with
the same reluctance to put the book down
he brings the past to life he writes the
kind of history that confirms the past
that makes you understand but all this
actually happened these people rarely
existed it's a rare gift and I feel
exhilarated to be alongside him today
for the last 40 years
I've been writing fiction novels short
stories books for children well before
that for a crucial three years I read
history at University
I've always liked that term that we use
reading a subject rather than studying
it which carries an appealing suggestion
of long-term inclination rather than
mandatory application and I think for
many people that's just what happens
does exposure to a particular range of
books to a particular academic inquiry
at the most susceptible time of your
life does indeed form a climate of mind
what your reading will determine up to a
point the person you will become reading
history at Oxford half a century ago
certainly did that for me
it didn't make me a novelist but it
determined the kind of fiction that I
would eventually write and I'd like to
talk about that this evening about one
novelists concern with the operation of
memory and the significance of a passion
for history I have to give a bit of
personal background at this point I
was born and grew up in Egypt before and
during the Second World War and I didn't
go to any school until I was 12 when I
arrived in England for the first time
and was sent to a boarding school on the
south coast it was a place of stern
philistinism at which one of the
punishments was to be sent to the
library to read a book for an hour when
eventually I emerged from this Calvary
it was with the assumption that reading
was a perverted activity in which you
indulged furtively and improvers it and
it came as a surprise to discover in due
course at university but others of my
age had been doing this openly for years
and that here was another set of
authority figures who were urging you to
do as much of it as possible there was a
sense of loss almost there'd been an
interesting challenge about cherishing a
subversive practice we did some history
at that school from a single book I
remember and I came away knowing that
history was a set of received facts
there was the past nicely laid out and
to understand about it you just had to
absorb this approved data I think I
chose to read history at rather than say
English because I felt deeply ignorant
about history I was intrigued by such
data as I'd come across and perhaps had
a sneaking feeling that there might be
more to it than that
my first Oxford tutorial was on the
anglo-saxon invasions and I was given us
an essay title who were the Jutes along
with a lengthy book list and with this
list in hand I plunged into the history
faculty library and within a couple of
days had discovered how profoundly I had
been misled by such history teaching as
I had had I discovered that history is a
matter of conflicting evidence of debate
and disagreement that received facts are
repeatedly challenged but history is a
question of shifting opinion and is
reinterpreted and rewritten again and
again I realized that there was no
simple answer to my essay question but
historians were still arguing about the
origins of the Jutes in which precise
areas of southern England they occupied
and that the interest of history was in
following up these arguments weighing
them up and indeed thinking about the
Jews the great advantage of the nineteen
year old mind is that it's able happily
to discard long-held assumptions when
these are demonstrably wrong and is
entirely open to persuasion which is why
we want nineteen year olds to go to
college I can still remember that heady
sense of Revelation and I retained an
affection for the Jutes whoever they may
have been for the next three years I
read on within the constrictions of then
Oxford history syllabus and it now seems
to me that the whole endeavor was a kind
of taster a process of wetting the
appetite I wasn't a shining student I
didn't get a particularly good degree
but I've spent the last fifty plus years
in leisurely serendipitous pursuit of
history trying to fill in the gaps left
by that syllabus getting sidetracked
into archeology of paleontology lighting
with glee on the kind of history that
was ignored by the oxford syllabus or
had not then been written the French are
now Keith Thomas's religions a Cline of
magic William Cronin's changes in the
land
Norman cones the pursuit of the Minnelli
millennium Frances Yeats is the art of
memory and much much more those three
years hadn't so much taught me history
as they taught me how to read history
how to follow up an interest cross it an
obsession explore and experiment I came
late to writing fiction into my 30s
before publishing anything unlike
today's Young Turks who seemed to be
fully fledged at twenty-one or so some
of them but I now see that what I wrote
right from the start it was conditioned
by those three years during which I
turned out the weekly essay without
being aware of the secret and compelling
process that was taking place reading
history had given me a concern with the
operation of memory itself with how it
works and what it does to us my response
was not a scholarly one but that of a
storyteller though when first it began
to blossom in the post college years of
of using my public library I didn't know
what it was that I wanted to be I was
interested in the operation of memory
the nature of evidence the way in which
there's no single truth about an event
but as many truths as there are
observers the conflicting evidence about
public events as mirrored by the
conflicting evidence about private life
which is grist to the mill of the
biographer but equally so to that of the
novelist and the novelist is omnipotence
can manipulate the evidence supply the
conflict explore the whole process of
distortion and misrepresentation I've
tried to do this in several novels and
in short stories and I've been equally
intrigued and inspired by the question
of choice and contingency by the way in
which we think that we direct our own
lives but are continually thrown off
course by contingent events whether they
be the malign intervention of the bus in
front of which we step or the invisible
direction of the processes of history
the conditioning of private lives by
public events reading history has made
me constantly aware of this grand
directive affecting everyone whether in
the drama of war or revolution or the
unobtrusive stealth of economic sir
circumstance and this concern has
frequently crept into a fiction I've had
characters picked off by history of
victims of war but I also had a
character whose entire life was directed
by a rise in the interest rate his
father a man with a hefty mortgage felt
obliged to cancel the holiday on the
Mediterranean and took his family to an
English beach where the ten-year-old son
acquires a handful of Jurassic fossils
and his career as a paleontologist is
given a kickstart let me go back for a
moment to the Oxford history syllabus of
the early 1950s you did the whole long
haul through English history starting
with the Romans who my tutor seems to
have skipped by launching me with an
essay on the anglo-saxon invasions
indeed some members of the faculty seem
to have felt that the hall was a trifle
too long and in the same spirit
the history fellows of my own college
had decided to miss out the 18th century
on the grounds that all the action is in
the 17th and the 19th and the time was
better spent on those a view that can be
challenged to say the least of it and
especially from this side of the
Atlantic but there were deficiencies in
the syllabus there was a special subject
paper on slavery and secession and that
was the only bow in the direction of
American history the Far East apparently
did not exist equally Africa it was a
Eurocentric syllabus though to its
credit it shot off into compulsory
papers on political theory the mantra
Aristotle Rousseau and Hobbes remains in
my head to this day and Latin
translation hmm I don't regret that
determined advance through English
history you need to understand from
whence you have sprung there I have to
admit that the 18th century still feels
in some way a no-go area I visit there
with diffidence as there I lack a
passport and as for the rest of the
gaping emissions well that was a
challenge for the future this was linear
chronological history one thing followed
another in neat sequential order much
later when reading and thinking about
history fed into the fiction I began to
write I found that what I was interested
in was the operation of memory itself
which of course is not linear at all
there's nothing sequential about the
stuff that each of us carries in the
head that set of frozen moments of
slides that will surface prompted or
unprompted and that served to remind us
who we are where we've been what we've
done who we've known everything happens
at once in the mind at some point in the
post college years I discovered
landscape history with a group of joy'
largely thanks to the great and good WG
Hoskins author of the making of the
English landscape I tramped around
Oxfordshire where we were then living in
search of the corrugations in a field
that indicate medieval Ridge and furrow
the lumps and bumps that betray a
deserted village the green lanes that
were once drove
and I became aware of the eloquence of
the physical world once you learned a
bit of its language as a nice reflection
of the process of memory itself all
around us everything happens at once
centuries are juxtaposed whether it be
the field pattern of the countryside or
the layout of town streets and the
coexistence of buildings that remember
quite different times and when I first
crossed the Atlantic and used to spend
summer holidays with American friends in
New England I was entranced at once by
the eloquence of this landscape by the
way in which architecture had a familiar
echo but was somehow more delicate more
elegance had undergone a sea change and
become native to this place and I was
lucky enough to have friends who could
explain what I was seeing so that the
stone walls lost in Massachusetts
woodlands spoke of old field boundaries
and the whole place could hint of what
went on once here Egypt where I grew up
has a landscape as tumultuous as
anywhere in the world their prehistory
rubbed shoulders with the world of today
pharaonic Egypt coincides with Roman
Egypt with the Mamluks with Napoleon the
Turks the French and the British have
left visible imprints I understood
little or none of this as a child but I
saw and heard and I grew up with
pyramids as unremarkable features I
registered vaguely that these catacombs
we were visiting had been made by folk
called the Romans when I arrived in
England at the age of 12 in 1945 I was
taken to see the bomb blasted area
around Saint Paul's Cathedral in the
heart of the old city of London which
was then an acreage of half standing
walls and rubble interiors which had
become lakes of opportunists purple
willow herb and at one point the bombs
had revealed the hidden structure of one
of the Roman bastions of the original
city wall
I remember being baffled by this and
intrigued Roman but we had Romans down
in Egypt how could they be up here to in
gray rainy England
clearly this landscape was seeing
something but what was it saying and I
see that moment now a Simenon early
glimpse of intellectual possibilities
you don't need a university degree in
order to become a writer I'm guessing
but I think it quite likely that the
majority of the finest novelists have
had no college education but I've never
come across or heard of a writer worth
their salt it was not an obsessive
reader books beget books each writer
springs from an individual seedbed of
ideas and concerns and influences you
read in order to discover taste and
affinity but also aversion to discover
what you admire and what you dislike you
read not to emulate but to discover the
possibilities of different forms to
discover what the novel can do what the
short story does that the novel cannot
and you go on doing that forever as far
as I'm concerned there are always
undiscovered treats the writer you've
never heard of or never tried the
Maverick forgotten title that kind of
reading for the writer of fiction is
what I think of as enlightenment reading
but there's also the other kind
inspirational reading which is that
whole raft of books from which your own
may arise and that kind of reading is
both deliberate and serendipitous for me
the serendipitous element while being
just that has also a certain determinism
about it and much is owed to the climate
of mind formed during those three
university years I've honed in on
history but history is a broad canvas
and I suppose that my special focus has
tended to be on the innovative history
writing of the later part of the last
century as I said earlier but also upon
areas of ignorance and of course the
luxury of a lifelong reading program is
that you're not going to be examined on
it I have a recurrent dream or nightmare
rather in which I have to do my finals
all over again and I know nothing
absolutely nothing I wake up in a lather
of anxiety now I suppose this can be
seen as a long-term effect of the
examination system but I suspect it may
also have something to do with the fact
that my worst mark was in the political
theory paper the time-honored Aristotle
Rousseau and Holmes and that I
subsequently married an academic a
political theorist I should say as he
never held this inadequacy against me
merely murmured that if he'd had
anything to do with this I'd have done
better but if history has been at the
center of this serendipitous reading
they've also been extended for A's in
other directions some of which have fed
into a particular novel or even prompted
one the kind of accessible science
writing of the last decades accessible
to the non scientist has been a treasure
trove I read Stephen Jay Gould spoke
wonderful life at a point when I was
thinking about the confusion of choice
and contingency that there is in
anyone's life and his accounts of the
fossils of the Burgess Shale there's
bizarre animals of the Cambrian period
all of which left no evolutionary trace
except for one which is the ancestor of
vertebrates and ourselves seems echo the
processes of contingency the mutation of
contingent events and it prompted a
novel called Cleopatra's sister in which
the principal character is a
paleontologist and which also takes a
rile up at the Cleopatra's nose theory
of history the proposition that if
Cleopatra's nose had been an inch longer
the course of history would have run
differently archeology has played a
theme tune for me right from the start
when I was in my second year at Oxford
the Roman temple of mithras in the heart
of the city of London had just been
discovered and was being excavated and I
read about this in The Times and that
the excavator professor Grimes was
making use of student volunteers so I
wrote him to say please could I come and
help on the dig during the long vacation
and I received a charming reply which I
don't have but remember very well in
which he said that unfortunately he was
not up to the neck in student volunteers
and couldn't use another one
but that he was glad to hear of my
interest in archaeology and that I might
like to consider a diploma in
archaeology when I'd finished my history
degree in which case I should write to
him and he would make some suggestions
well I never did in the event life took
a different turn in the year or two
following University but it very well
might not have done I might have written
to him I might have had another life
altogether I often feel that I have some
alter ego who has beaver Dawei for
decades as an archaeologist and perhaps
in compensation archaeology is fed into
fiction to the extent that one early
novel treasures of time lifted entirely
from Wessex and it's prehistoric
landscape while archaeologists have made
guest appearances elsewhere
all of this allowing me the indulgence
of immersion in the books that would
help me to get things right which takes
me on to the other kind of reading
that's the necessary support system
deliberate reading research actually I
shy away from the word research which
carries overtones of scholarship a
novelist
is not a scholar the accuracies sorter
of a different kind they may be large
general accuracies such as the
background to the North African campaign
of the Second World War what the
battlefield what the battlegrounds
looked like what a man would have seen
and heard from a tank the speech and
attitudes of a young officer or they may
be entirely precise the names of mix of
Japanese motorcycles some details of a
likely project for a garden designer I
fished these examples out more or less
at random because they've all occupied
me at some point a novel called moon
tiger has the Lybian campaign as a
crucial element I spent many hours in
the Imperial War Museum in London in
pursuit of the background material for
that book watching the mute unedited
film taken by the official cameraman
attached to each battalion which was the
source material for the the paratha
pictorial and Movietone propaganda films
of the day and I read everything I could
hands-on that would give me some idea of
the immediacy zuv tank warfare war
Diaries and the accounts of war
correspondence and the handful of novels
devoted to the Libyan campaign because I
was planning to stick my neck out as a
middle-aged woman novelist and write one
section from the point of view of a
young tank officer but there's a caveat
here I think for anyone writing fiction
that's dependent on a degree of
background reading
none of this should show it's the
ballast without which the whole
enterprise would capsize it's the seven
eighths of the iceberg you need to know
more about the area of which you're
going to write then you will actually
use so that what is used seeps in
effortlessly and naturally there mustn't
be a hint of the card index I've never
written historical novels or though I
agree with anyone who's objecting that
to write of the nineteen forties is to
be writing a historical novel even if
you're yourself or around then even if
only aged nine or ten but that was only
a glance most of that particular book is
set later in the century I'm thinking of
the full-blown historical novel the on
which I actually cut my my teenage
reading teeth the body strippers like
georgette hare and others much enjoyment
was hand I may say but I came in time to
see these as good fun but nothing
whatsoever to do with the past for me
they'd give him the historical novel a
bad name all of that has changed the
historical novel has been redeemed by a
raft of writers over the last 30 years
or so beginning with John Fowles and the
French Lieutenant's woman through novels
by JD Farrell to a number of number of
Anglophone writers of today American
British Australian Canadian fiction
that's a serious consideration of the
past but that's also compelling fiction
because crucially the supportive card
index is invisible they seem to have
risen effortlessly from the writers
imagination a quick glance for a moment
at that other kind of research for ones
of a more appropriate word but Japanese
motorcycle
and the garden designs this kind of
challenge crops up with every novel you
simply set to and find out ideally you
need amongst your acquaintances a
compliant medic and a legal practitioner
it's amazing how often health and the
law are frequent pitfalls but the point
is that accuracy is essential not just
for creative satisfaction but because
you can be sure that if you have
stumbled some sharp-eyed reader will be
happy to point this out one such did
this recently was reference to a book
written 20 years ago and I still cringe
and snarl at myself of 20 years ago for
not checking carefully enough now I'm
beginning to make writing fiction sound
like a matter of extended reference work
a library based exercise it's not of
course unless the essential primal
inspiration is there the story that must
be told no amounts of crafted background
work is going to put life into the end
product I've spent many hours in
libraries mainly the British Library in
London to which I owe a huge debt of
gratitude and not least because my
association with it brought me my
friendship with Alice Prohaska now
Yale's librarian but for me and for any
writer of fiction the Lightning does not
strike from the pages of a book but from
life as lived and observed you write out
of experience and observation characters
of Dirac devised from what you have
discovered of other people and of
yourself narrative is pure invention and
imagination no amount of reading or
checking is going to help you with that
moreover there are many writers whose
work will not require much of this
support system if any but for plenty of
novelists books are the basic
nutritional requirements and I'm
certainly one of them whether it be as
the long-term lifetime diet or for the
enrichment of the work in progress which
brings me to the question of supply and
it seems appropriate under the auspices
of one of the world's great libraries as
we are to talk about a relationship with
libraries
when I was 18 an uncle who had noticed
that I seemed to be a bookish sort of
girl gave me temporary membership of the
London library which is an August
private institution as a birthday
present
I'd never been inside such a library
before and was much impressed but
determined not to be too awestruck to
profit I had no idea what I wanted to
read except that something historical
would suit I consulted the card index
and for some obscure reason came up with
Hackl its voyage around the world at
that time
London library books must have been
delivered to the reader and in due
course it arrived on a trolley in about
ten volumes i sat stolid Lee reading for
a week too embarrassed to admit defeat
new students at Oxford admitted as
readers to the body and library and I do
have a vague vestigial memory of some
rather intimidating ceremony in one of
the library in one of the library's
inner and most ancient bits Duke
Humphreys library I think involving
Latin and a declaration that you would
honor and respect the library for the
next three years I spent much of my time
in the Radcliffe Camera which is the
history faculty library
competing with others for the crucial
titles on the list for that week's essay
there was amiable competition with those
from other colleges who had the same
essay title that week as you did the
sprint to get to the library first when
it opened and if you'd lost out the
search for the desk at which the victor
set and the whispered request to have
the book when he'd finished usually a he
those were the days when men outnumbered
women by ten to one at Oxford which
sometimes triggered a flirtation
libraries are notorious hot beds of
romance access to a great library is a
sobering experience for a student that
dire school of mine in which the library
was a place of punishment was now shown
up in all its savagery and ignorance I
saw was a great library was a place
which was not just a shrine to the book
but was also infinite a bottomless well
from which
could call up anything and everything
not that you would have dared to do so I
was intimidated by the bot lien but also
it properly reverent and nervous of the
librarians on duty in the reading room
who treated undergraduates were the kind
of stern tolerance as necessary
impediment oh should be kept in their
place and made properly aware of their
status as transitory readers but for me
a taste had been kindled I knew that I
was no scholar and never would be but I
knew the library was not only a kind of
sanctuary but also in a way that I did
not yet understand a source of
Revelation a gateway to unimaginable
glimpse somehow sideways while doing the
required reading for an essay on the
causes of the English Civil War or these
significance of the Chartist movement
the English Public Library System used
to be one of the glories of my country
as it is of yours I say it used to be
because it's been hideously eroded by
underfunding over the last decades so
that the typical branch library seems
nowadays to be more closed than open and
books more often D accessioned to use
that inelegant library term than
acquired but back when the going was
good the public libraries were famously
the great resource for those unsupported
by university librarian and the system a
wonderfully broad Church that catered
both for those in search of a crime
novel they hadn't yet read before and
the tyro general reader who needed a
range of everything in order to find out
what they actually wanted and I became
one of these as a house bound young
mother wheeling the pram to the local
branch library with the baby the books
and the shopping all bundled in together
the library it was just a couple of
large rooms but its aspirations were
admirable
there was a determined coverage of
history travel biography with forays
into sociology psychology and a fine
array of fiction which included most of
the important novelists of the 20th
century and it was here that I began to
read my way through early and mid 20th
century fiction discovering taste and
diversion discovering what the novel can
do
it would be several years before I
thought of having a go myself and I see
that time as a crucial warming up period
three years of history and another three
or four learning the possibilities of
fiction an apprenticeship so heartfelt
thanks to the Public Library System in
time my reading needs became more
demanding than could be met by a branch
library and the British Library became a
necessity by which time I was a library
addict a library is a metaphor for
memory they are onyx shell silent and
eloquent is everything that has been
thought or done from the contents of a
great library you could unravel what we
have been what humankind has achieved in
the old round Reading Room when the
British Library was still housed within
the British Museum I used to have a
fantasy in idle moments in which the
human race was extinguished long since
dead and gone all the systems are down
and forever so proving the unreliability
of electronic retrieval systems and into
the reading room pad the advance guard
of an alien race taking down the volumes
of the old catalogue with their long
green fingers peering at the entries
with their multifaceted eyes crack teams
of scholars are set to work to decode
this mystifying depository there's
nothing to indicate degrees of
significance everything coexists here
the several task forces penetrate the
inner reaches of the library and inspect
the Lindisfarne Gospels alongside a set
of eighteenth-century sermons handles
manuscripts in conjunction with studies
and accountancy the works of Dickens in
association with beekeeping for
beginners what were the priorities of
this culture they were Wonder they will
become aware of linguistic diversity and
above all of interconnection the study
group assigned to the Tyndale Bible will
be able to announce after several
decades but echoes of the
apparently unremarkable little work
appear in such a range of other material
but it's clear that a primitive virus
has been identified in time they will
arrive at the distinction between fact
and fiction and understand that a vast
quantity of the material in front of
them is fabulous it invents it tells
stories it tells lies and they will
start to identify and investigate the
strangely repetitive concerns of this
immense collection the way in which one
theme will reverberate elsewhere the way
in which it seems the books have spawned
other books the word intertextuality
will be muttered in monstrous alien
speech a novelist is one cog in this
immense ongoing intertextual process we
none of us right out of a vacuum rewrite
out of diverse personal experience but
we write also out of a time and a place
out of a particular culture we reflect
it we comment on it and do so in a
multitude of different ways which is why
the world can tolerate quite a few
novelists all writers of fiction pillage
their particular circumstances whether
in search of the action that will drive
the story or simply by making the most
of the cards that they've been dealt I
know myself to be one of those whom
inspiration has come as much from what
I've read as from experience reading has
supplied the idea behind the novel
experience has created the characters
and their behavior and this strange
compulsion to invent has powered the
story I often wondered if I'd go on
writing of entirely deprived of books
yes I fear so inevitably but the writing
would be different and would have been
something other from the start without
this lifelong fertilizer I've recently
been enjoying the essay collections of
Anne Fadiman who's currently Yale's
writer in residence erudite eclectic
witty and above all reflecting a
multitude of other writings they made me
think about the way in which a
well-furnished mind is it Salford
kind of virtual library a receptacle
into which has been poured a quantity of
quite disparate data all of which floats
around degrading to some degree but
available in all sorts of ways whether
serving up the answers to quiz questions
or powering a literary reflection on
Arctic exploration to take just one of
Anne Fadiman subjects anyone for whom
reading has been a central activity
carries around such a depository
accessible only to themselves the
ultimate private reference library and
anyone who ends up writing knows that
they've been primed by this memory bank
because reading it seems to me supplies
for those who do it with intensity a
kind of alternative to the memories
supplied by lived experience
there's the strange vivid apparently
random set of slides in the mind places
faces words spoken which confirms
identity tells us who we are and what's
happened to us but there's also this
great raft of language of imagery of
information which is communal property
plenty of others have it as well but
it's also personal because only we have
it in just this association we've come
across it or chosen it or had it thrust
upon us and the whole becomes this other
confirmation of identity from here has
come the way in which we think and much
of much of what we think about its the
minds memory there's a brilliant short
book by the British writer Frances
Spofford called the child that books
built in which the author examines the
way in which his own moral and social
outlook was formed by childhood reading
by immersion at that most susceptible
time of life in a great swathe of books
from Maurice Sendak to Tolkien Rosemarie
Sutcliffe Arthur Ransome Ursula Le Guin
Laura Ingalls Wilder he discusses the
childhood education in psychology in the
nature of evil in moral conduct in how
people behave and how we behave
ourselves but seeps from children's
literature just as much as from any
writing for adults a memory bank that
starts up the first time some adult
opens a book and begins to read aloud to
a child and that becomes loaded from
that magical moment when a child cracks
the Croat code itself and grows wings a
reader I psyched this because it seems
to me that this shaping of identity this
accumulation of Ballas that will sustain
a person for the rest of life begins
with serendipitous acquisition only
later does the process of focus and
direction begin and any child is of
course entirely dependent on
circumstance whether or not books come
its way at all essential to my own
childhood reading was Greek mythology by
way of that late Victorian retailer of
the Iliad Andrew Lang now posit the
fascination was that there I was myself
right at the heart of the story of
Penelope so clearly this must have some
personal relevance at the age of eight
or nine one's grasp of the distinction
between myth and reality is not great
the only problem was that I was in there
with the wrong part Penelope is
described as being wise and good
qualities which did not have much appeal
and it's made clear that she's not as
beautiful as Helen well Odysseus is
short of stature has red hair is
perceived as untrustworthy and is not a
patch on Hector or Achilles so I said
about some retelling of my own jigged
things around a bit airbrushed the
irritating Helen and upgraded Odysseus I
couldn't know that I was entering a fine
tradition the Iliad and the Odyssey have
been raided for centuries and I now see
what I was up to as a first response to
Magisterial storytelling and an early
foray into making things up for myself
I've been concerned today with the way
in which for me exposure to a particular
discipline history eventually fueled the
writing of fiction and have strayed
necessarily into a wider question the
sense in which were all products of what
we've read
scientists identify the different
functions of memory procedural memory is
the function that reminds you how to
ride a bicycle or drive a car semantic
memory tells you that a vehicle with two
wheels is a bicycle well episodic memory
gives you identity it tells you where
you've been and what you've done it
always seems to me that reading memory
somehow bridges these last two
categories and becomes a fourth and
different function it's both the source
of a great body of information and
imagery but it also identifies the mind
it tells us where our minds have been
and what they've been expanded and what
they've been exposed to and how they
have responded the retrieval system is
of course faulty there's much material
in there of which we're apparently
unaware but it can float miraculously to
the surface prompted by something else
read or heard we remember what we once
knew another function of memory
associative memory and the quirky
individual nature of the entire
collection identifies us my collection
is stuffed with history and related
matter conservation may be a bit behind
hand but acquisitions are still coming
in your collection will be utterly
different there there will be plenty of
duplication which gives us common ground
and joins us to a culture and it's this
factor I find so enriching the language
of reading which is universal we may
each of us find different significance
in a book but we're listening to the
same language we're part of the
community that's been exposed to this
particular work as readers we respond to
that element which seems to speak to us
which strikes a chord
whatever we're reading fact or fiction
prose or poetry and a writer writes out
of this accumulated influence and
experience and hopes to find imaginative
empathy in readers I never cease to be
amazed that the reciprocity of this
arrangement the way in which we all
derive an aspect of ourselves from what
we've read what we're reading whether as
writers or as readers
thank you
there are there is nothing in life quite
like discovering for the first time a
wonderful writer a writer you've never
read before and I had that experience
just recently in the last few years I
sat one night at a library dinner beside
Alice Prohaska and asked her what she's
been reading and she said Penelope
lively and that was my beginning and I'm
I'm still at it I've read I'm on my
fifth of Penelope's books and I'm
delighted to say there are still a dozen
some still to go and I was particularly
pleased with the first book that I
embarked on mooned tiger that she writes
very early in the book I have always
been interested in beginnings my
beginning with moon tiger was for me one
of the most delightful valuable
rewarding experiences of my reading life
and it is a particular pleasure and
honor and something of a challenge to
respond to that wonderful talk we've
just heard a talk which reminds all of
us of what is at the heart of a really
truly great University that it brings
people such as mrs. lively to this
community I want to read you how moon
tiger begins since we are interested in
beginnings
this is this is a scene that I find
utterly riveting from the very first
lines and I'm very interested in
beginnings I have studied beginnings of
novels histories movies because very
often that's exactly when the author or
the or the screenwriter or the
playwright is telling you what is going
to be about
it's where the story is launched and
it's not just direction place but tone
and what what sparks our curiosity I'm
writing a history of the world she says
and the hands of the nurse are arrested
for a moment she looks down at this old
woman this old ill woman well my
goodness the nurse says that's quite a
thing to be doing isn't it and then she
becomes busy again she heaves and
touches and smooth up see a bit dear
that's a good girl
then we'll get you a cup of tea now
watch what's going on there
I'm writing a history of the world she
says and then the nurse we cut to the
nurse and it's her hands that are busy
well my goodness says the nurse that's
quite a thing to be doing isn't it just
a touch pattern I see and then she's
becomes busy again she he wasn't I
tuckson smooth up see a bit dear that's
a good girl she's a little girl and then
we'll get you a cup of tea as if that
will solve all problems and then the
protagonist Claudia Hampton launches
into her story and we're on the way and
it's a story what once you've read it
that you'll never forget in part because
it's all mixed up in time and imagery
it isn't lineal
I I have been listening particularly
today to ideas about writing concepts
about writing that would apply perfectly
to my specialty to my choice as a writer
my field and I'm reminded of some of the
admonitions that I've taken to heart
one was from Delacroix's journal in
which he says what I demand is accuracy
for the sake of imagination
another is Dickens famous admonition to
writers make me see in that opening
paragraph of moon tiger you see though
it's done with a with a minimum of
strokes another that I take heart from
is a line from JH plumb the British
historian in which he said what we need
are more heart wise historians not
intellectually vibrant heart wise
historians and then finally something
that was said by a professor of child
psychology at the University of
Pittsburgh years ago Margaret McFarland
who in many ways may have been the most
effective teacher of teachers who ever
lived her point was that what matters
most in the classroom whether it's a
teacher who's working with seven year
olds or graduate students is the
attitude of the teacher that that's what
prevails in teaching and she said
attitudes aren't taught they're caught
show them what you love well I would
like to show you what I love about
Penelope lives Lee's writing I love the
fact that she doesn't tell you
everything she knows I love the fact
that she doesn't as some historians do
take all of her notes and dump them into
the book I love the fact that she knows
what to leave out in order to make the
emphasis of what matters all the clearer
I love the fact that she has humor as
we've seen today because humanity
without humor isn't humanity history is
human whether it's written as history or
biography or whether it's written as
fiction I'm also reminded by her work
something that the old the old complaint
of the piano teacher the old piano
teacher I hear all the milk I hear all
the notes but I hear no music when she
writes you hear the music when all to
many historians or biographers right all
you get are the notes and this is this
need not be so historians can learn
immensely and and in valuable ways from
the great writers of fiction and poetry
and drama just as writers of fiction
such as Penelope Lively have learned
enormous amounts from history and
biography in a way she and I have had
the reverse experience she began as a
student of history and turned to fiction
I was an English major here at Yale and
quite by chance stumbled into history
and I'm sure that that the one of the
themes of mrs. lively spokes of the how
fate or happenstance impinges on life
that in my own experience is exactly
what happened I happen to find something
that inspired me but take it take a try
to take a crack at writing a first book
I love her vocabulary and I I'm in awe
of her vocabulary I often have to turn
to the dictionary to make sure I really
do understand that word
torpid now I won't ask any presenting
show of hands but it means mentally and
physically inactive as in a torpid pig
asleep in a patch of shade torpid
wonderful word phew matauri a plant with
spikes of a smoke of small pink or white
flowers mell a lot a fragrant plant of
the pea family demotic i thought it must
have some into a demon's demotic
everyday speech conurbation an extended
urban area in electable inescapable and
then she uses wonderful good old plain
words like pigheaded and happenstance
and then right in exactly the right
place and then she combines words which
demonstrate superbly that the sum is
very often far more that the whole is
very often far more than the sum of the
parts laziness of the soul
isn't that beautiful vital in essentials
she used that expression to describe a
spaniel a dog that was on board the
Mayflower knowing about that dog is
vital to understanding those people who
were on the Mayflower and their
experience once they landed but it was
also in in essential sycophantic
gusto I love this one profoundly
uninteresting and at monetary smile a
new lot of jumped-up nobodies how much
does that describe of various
communities we've all been to
large-scale historical evil tacit
collusion think of that tacit collusion
I and of course I love what she does
with history and what she says about
history and I'm just gonna give you a
few examples the past is public property
amen absolutely it's all in the public
domain so to speak
history is disorder it isn't neat it
isn't clean it isn't logical
the voice of history is of course a
composite history unravels in life as in
history the unexpected lies waiting
grinning from around corners one of
these simplest lessons of all which I
try to convey and what I write in court
and when I am with students is that
nothing had to happen the way it
happened just as in our own lives there
so often taught that this follows this
follow that all of that and you better
get it straight because it's gonna be on
the test on Wednesday that they bag they
get the idea that had to happen that way
it had to turn out as it did it never
had to turn out as it did nobody's
exempt from history she writes in
consequences or they
snob in Moon Tiger what she reads read
writes this one has this tendency to
think oneself immune from history and of
course no one is if I had to list the
lessons of history of course it would go
on endlessly until the end of life there
are innumerable manifold lessons of
history but among them that I take quite
to heart are the following the first is
that no one who lived in times past no
one who lived long ago thought they
lived in times past or long ago in a way
there's no such thing as the past in
that no one lived in it they lived in
the present but it was their present not
ours and different from ours Washington
Jefferson Adams George the third they
didn't walk around say he's this
fascinating living in the past and so
you have to put yourself into their
present another one is that there's no
such thing as a self-made man or
self-made woman we are all everyone and
always have it has always been this way
the result of innumerable influences of
people who have guided us or inspired us
or been rivals or foes people who have
stepped out of their way to make things
happen for us and people of course that
we never knew because we read about them
in books or we attended the concert that
moved us to our depths of our souls and
they lived long before we happened on
the scene on a campus in California not
long ago after a talk I was asked during
the question and answer period besides
Harry Truman and John Adams how many
other presidents have you interviewed
I tried to explain that appearances
notwithstanding I I in fact never met
either man but but I didn't I do know
them I do know them I know them as well
in many ways or better than I know
people in real life because I've read
what they've written I've read their
letters you don't get to read other
people's mail in real life and of course
now we don't write any letters and in
some cases they were they were letter
writers who just poured out everything
Adams in particular or Abigail Adams all
of their worries fears innermost
thoughts
their jealousies all of it's all there
you don't the speculate about it's all
there and because they're writing each
other it's absolutely genuine because
either one would know when the other was
faking it or doing it for the record so
to speak but I not only tribe have tried
to read what they wrote but to read what
they read because just as Penelope
lively said in her wonderful talk we are
to a very large degree what we read and
you have to understand the culture of
the people you're trying to understand
in order to understand them it's simple
and it's it's grievous mistake to think
that they because they were human beings
and and resembled us physically in many
ways and had many of the same
experiences that tomato tasted roughly
the same as it does for us or that the
stars in the sky look more or less the
same that they were just like we are
they were not just like we are because
they lived in a different time and so in
the case of John Adams and Abigail I
tried to read all the English writers
that they adored novelists built
political philosophers Pope Swift Daniel
Defoe Cervantes Shakespeare Samuel
Johnson and I found myself going back
and reading writers that most of us had
to read in English courses in
high school or college and I was
reminded again what a classic really is
and why it is a classic because it
survives the test of time it's as fresh
and as real today is the day it was
written but it speak to us speaks to us
of a different world and very often in
the letters of John and Abigail Adams
they will quote a line from something
that they really love someone like Defoe
or Swift and there's no quotation marks
around it because in the 18th century
they didn't had no rules of punctuation
and they know that the recipient of the
letter knows the line just as well as
they do they are sharing something that
they love if we wrote a letter today and
said well I guess it will just have to
follow the yellow brick road we probably
wouldn't put quotation marks around that
because that's part of who we are we
know that line and what it means so it's
the same it was the same with them one
of the charming charming things about
Abigail Adams letters is that she almost
always quotes something from poetry or
Shakespeare that she loved and and it's
always appropriate always apt and it's
always just a little bit wrong which
tells us she wasn't looking it up she
wasn't reaching for the 18th century
equivalent of Bartlett's familiar
quotations which of course didn't exist
and taking it down and put it in putting
it into the letter in order to look
well-read or Harry died no it's part of
her it just comes out of her and and you
know her that way john adams carried
servantes in the saddle bag of won his
rounds as a young attorney riding the
court circuit in massachusetts and you
know what that means if he was carrying
it all the time I wonder if how many of
you know how often we all quote
servantes almost every day take out
Bartlett's familiar quotations and look
at all the the expressions that we'd use
all the time we're quoting Shakespeare
every day we quote Alexander Pope every
day and we don't know it it's part of
who we are and
was thinking too and as I read this
wonderful course of literature that
meant so much to my protagonists how we
all of us are far more steeped saturated
in English literature than we ever give
credit for from Beatrix Potter to
Kenneth Grahame to Robert Louis
Stevenson in childhood let's say on up
to all the greats of the kinds I've just
mentioned and on into the 20th century
and and it's part of us and so it's very
natural it seems to me for this
university and for all of us to
recognize that we are continuing in that
tradition in reading the great works of
Penelope lively I don't think that that
any of us can fail to learn something
from reading great works of literature
and I also feel very strongly that it's
perfectly possible to have all the facts
exactly right and miss the truth just as
it's perfectly possible to get a lot of
the facts wrong or to mess them up a
little bit and hit the truth right on
the bullseye and novelists do that more
often than not but there's no reason why
historians can't
I think historians and biographers
especially need to know more about the
art of writing and to us to aspire to
writing history in biography that might
just might qualify as literature because
that's the only way history is going to
live and not just be sort of a trade
journal for the enlightened I'm I'm
thrilled when I read someone new and am
transported in a way I've never been
someone said maybe somebody and some of
you know who said it even the oldest
book is brand new to he who has never
opened it before and it's a new
experience
I've I've been very fortunate in my
reading very fortunate in people who've
guided me in my reading and in my
writing and two of the people who had
the most influence on me in my writing
were novelist
Konrad Richter and Paul Horgan Paul
Horgan whose papers by the way are here
in the Yale collection and I learned so
much about about how the language is
used how not to trow on the historic
color how to try and keep hold back on
details except if they really mean
something if they really tell us
something and to see I'm appalled at how
often a fine work of history or
biography biography never bothers to
tell you what the characters looked like
you can take down some of these
dictionaries of biography and read every
incredible in a conceivable detail and
they had to ever tells you how tall they
were what color their eyes were and and
what they look like or what their
weaknesses or or physical handicaps may
have been which may be the as important
as anything one can know about them well
among the other points that mrs. lively
makes about history is in again her
wonderful novel moon tiger in which
Claudia Hampton says I she is the
historian I have the last the last word
that's the historians privilege and so
it's my last word privilege to say the
Penelope Lively is pure gold and if
there's anything more exciting more
uplifting more intellectually
stimulating than read reading Penelope
lively for the first time it's reading
her
second time